يقول الحشد الشعبي او مصادر في الحشد
الشعبي ان طيرانا امريكيا مسيرا نفذ هجوما
على مركبه يستقلها السعيدي
ومرافقه داخل مقر للدعم اللوجستي للحشد
الشعبي في وسط بغداد هذه هي السياره التي
استهدفت بالقرب من وزاره الداخليه
العراقيه التي واضحه في الافق حركه
النجباء في بيان لها قالت
ان المستهدف
هو نائب قائد حزام بغداد نائب قائد عمليات
حزام بغداد في الحشد الشعبي قالت انه
استشهد مع مرافقه في
هذه المركبه الحكومه العراقيه
اصدرت بيانا قبل قليل و قالت بانه اعتداء
سافر وصارخ على السياده العراقيه
وامن العراق وقالت بان طائره مسيره اقدمت
على عمل لا يختلف عن الاعمال الارهابيه
البيان الحكومي يحمل بوضوح التحالف الدولي
بقياده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مسؤوليه هذا الهجوم يقول بان الهجوم نفذ
على مقر لقوه امنيه تعمل وفق الصلاحيات
الممنوحه لها من قبل القائد العام لقوات
المسلحه رئيس الوزراء محمد شياع السوداني
التحالف الدولي وبحسب الحكومه العراقيه
يعمل لتقديم الاستشارات الامنيه وتدريب
القوات الامنيه ولكن الفصائل العراقيه في
العراق المنضوي تحت مسمى المقاومه
الاسلاميه في العراق لا تعترف بهذا الوصف
تقول بان التواجد الامريكي والتحالف
الدولي في البلاد هو تواجد
عسكري هذا المقر
تحيطه مناطق سكنيه وايضا دوائر رسميه
ابرزها وزاره الداخليه التي تبعد
نحو كيلومتر واحد من مكان الاستهداف من
هذه السياره الواضحه
امامكم